Please give a warm welcome to today's speaker,
a designer and Gardner,
the Ionic Cornelius.
You're very welcome to my talk on dream gardens.
I'm absolutely delighted to be here.
Um,
it's a really a real honor.
I have to admit,
I've never actually given this talk to a group of people that may or may not
have an interest in gardens.
So it's always been like garden festivals and you know,
kind of garden design courses and things like that.
So,
um,
over the past week or so I've been kind of going,
oh my God,
how am I going to make these guys not fall asleep?
Um,
and how,
how do we make it relevant to what you guys actually do?
Um,
and it actually got me thinking about the overlap,
um,
and the core of what we do as designers,
as people that offer a service.
Um,
and um,
really what kind of I could of,
what kind of boil down to for me was that we offer an experience and we provide
an experience.
And that's something that's really important to me because I'm really interested
in,
in people and in how people experience a space,
a garden,
um,
how they walk into it and feel like from an emotional point of view.
Um,
and I think that's,
that has a lot of kind of overlap with what you guys do because what you're
providing is an online,
a virtual experience.
And um,
the overlap there is that if it doesn't feel good and if it doesn't feel right,
the user has gone immediately.
So same thing in a garden.
If it's a badly designed space,
um,
and it's not natural to move through and feels good,
these are just never going to actually go out into their space.
You know,
you can't move around a space if it doesn't circulate well,
et Cetera.
So there's a lot of kinds of similarities and core principles that overlap.
So within the virtual experience and the tangible,
the garden,
we have a lot of overlaps,
like making a space or an experience,
the experience more usable,
a more inspiring,
more accessible,
more forward thinking.
Probably more so for you guys then in my role as a garden designer.
But having said that,
there's so much you can do to think ahead.
Um,
even in garden design,
sustainability,
et Cetera,
um,
more beautiful and,
obviously more joyful.
And by that I mean that you either go,
you go onto webpage and it feels good or you go into a garden and it feels good.
And there's a huge amount of that in the book,
um,
in how you experience a space and how it makes you feel.
And that's always something I've been interested in because my mom is a
psychotherapist.
Um,
so we've always kind of talk things to absolute death,
um,
and it kind of bled into my work as well.
Um,
so the talk in a way,
I mean,
there's plenty of garden stuff there and most of it is gardens,
but it's not just about gardens,
it's about,
um,
it's about people and about experiences and about emotional reactions to spaces.
Um,
so for today's garden design talk,
the talk is about you because you guys are actually the clients in this
situation.
So I want you to think,
right,
I want to design something in this and come away with something that can
actually be used in your own spaces.
So whether you have a balcony or a little patio or a huge field or some,
uh,
friends,
um,
space that you want to think about,
it's worth kind of thinking about us as we go along.
And maybe just having something to take away from it that really inspires you.
So,
um,
the most important thing I think is when I go into somebody's space is who is
that person?
So I kind of try and leave my ego at the door when I go into somebody's space
and it's all about that person.
So in this instance is about you and you need to think about who am I?
Um,
you know,
if you're thinking about designing a garden,
outdoor space for yourselves,
how do I live?
How do I spend my day in the garden?
And that's often it's thought about,
but it's not given enough attention.
Um,
so what you're thinking about is what do you like,
what's your lifestyle?
How do you spend time in the garden?
Um,
you know,
who,
who are you on a,
on a personal level?
Do you have kids,
pets?
Um,
do you read write sports?
So they're all incredibly important elements to consider when you go about
designing any kind of a space because that's kind of who you are from a
lifestyle perspective.
But when I started writing my book,
um,
I kind of realized that a lot of garden design books go straight into that.
And yes,
that's really important,
but there's something else which is really important.
Um,
and which often does get completely forgotten about and that's your dreams for
the space.
And a few people were like,
oh,
you have dreams.
You know,
why,
why do you have to dream and all that?
You can just say,
I want that Nice Garden.
And again,
probably because my mom's a psychotherapist,
I like to take that step back and just think,
no,
it's good to dream and it's good to,
um,
open your mind before you start going into detail and into functions and clothes
lines and compost bins and all of that stuff,
which has nothing to do with dreams.
It's just practical and function.
So in this instance,
your dreams are your,
your vision of your perfect space.
So gardens are intensely personal.
Um,
just like interior design,
is there part of you,
part of your home in the,
in the best scenario,
they're extensions of your living space.
And that's why I think it's really important to kind of go into that in a little
bit of detail,
um,
before you start looking at practicalities and functions and,
things like that.
So there are different from your functional requirements,
um,
because they're personal and they're made up of memories of,
you know,
times you spent in gardens where you felt amazing,
um,
or just,
you know,
say your grandmother's garden where you have a memory of personal connection to
the past or to,
to people.
Um,
so there's a lot more to it than just dreaming up a nice little space.
But one massive thing,
even if you have a balcony,
even if you have a very small,
one thing I always say is at this stage dream big.
Um,
and I know you're not going to have the Taj Mahal on your balcony or you know,
in a small patio space,
but you can take elements of your,
the biggest dream that you can possibly have and condense those elements down.
Um,
there is an exercise in my book which is called a dream,
uh,
gardens diagram,
which is just based around identifying what it is you love about that.
So if you were looking at that and you know,
that was the space that you choose for the exercise,
then you can zoom in on certain areas and say,
well,
I love the symmetry.
I love the detail of the filigree filigree work.
I love the planting,
I love the water,
the reflections,
the cam,
whatever it is.
You can pull all those together and they can become your concept.
Um,
so at this stage there are no limits.
And again,
like every time I go into somebody's space,
they start going,
okay,
and now I need the patty,
or now I need that and you know,
I need to circulation route to here and I always have to stop people and go,
no,
just go back to,
you know,
be completely mad for awhile before you start getting practical.
So there,
there is no,
there are no limits to this stage.
Just Dreaming Up,
you know,
your perfect space.
Um,
I never know why I include this one,
but for some reason it always makes me zoom out of base in my own head.
So I've left it in just for the sake of kind of underlining that idea of zooming
out and not getting into the nitty gritty of,
um,
of detail at this point.
So the exercise that I have in the book,
um,
is really based on just a memory of a place where you were really,
really happy.
So thinking of,
of a garden that you visited or a memory that you have of having been in a
garden and it doesn't even need to be,
you know,
perfectly designed,
it can be completely wild meadows scape or anything like that.
Um,
and,
um,
you basically what you're doing is you're thinking about what made that space
feel so good to you.
Why was it,
why did you have a personal connection to it?
Um,
you know,
was it the phone was at the cemetery,
the wildness of drama.
So each space,
and that's something you guys can do later on if you want or take the books home
and it's,
it's all kind of outlined in that too.
And it's a really good,
it sounds like a very simple exercise,
but it's a really good way of allowing yourself to not design before you design.
So just going,
oh,
I love that space.
I,
I really enjoyed that space.
So this is my one.
Um,
unless somebody else wants to give me one.
It's,
um,
I love the Alhambra in the south of Spain,
which is an amazing,
absolutely amazing garden.
Um,
and palace.
And there morrish gardens,
they're really symmetrical but yet the planting is really wild and free.
So I love that combination of that,
those kind of the perfect architecture and then the wild planting.
So for me it was,
you know,
the timeless feel of at the balance,
the water,
the wild planting,
the harmony.
And this is the exercise.
What you're doing is a simple sketch,
a spider diagram,
and you're putting the characteristics of the space above and the moods below.
So the moods of this space actually become your concept of your garden design.
So you need to think,
right,
that's what I want to bring to my own space.
And even if it is a balcony,
you know,
there's balance,
there's calm,
you want to feel at ease,
you want to feel happier,
you want to feel freer.
If,
say you went for a meadow that you felt incredibly happy in an a memory that you
have,
there's so many ways of bringing elements of a meadow,
the movement of the grasses,
uh,
looking at the wide open sky,
why not try and create something that kind of emulates that feel?
Even if it is a tiny balcony year,
um,
a small patio.
So really that's just about taking those and bringing them into your concept.
So for me it was the Alhambra,
um,
creating a calm space inspired by,
by a morrish palace.
Yet the planting is wild,
so there's not too much perfection going on,
which you know,
can become boring and you're never going to actually be able to achieve and
maintain.
Anyway.
Um,
so that's your new found concept.
So that was my scenario there.
Cam Space inspired by the Alhambra Gardens in Spain with wild natural planting,
plenty of water at a timeless feel.
So really simple,
but there's so many elements than that you can choose,
pick out and build into your design.
So that informs your materials,
your colors,
your water features.
It's easy then because I think a lot of people don't know where to start.
So this is a great way of kind of identifying a concept and then going right,
the paving I need to get needs to match that feel and the water needs to match
that and everything needs to follow that field and underlying that.
And then a concept and a garden works naturally and it's not disjointed.
So the next part is,
um,
form follows function,
which was,
uh,
which Louis Sullivan said.
And um,
as you guys know,
if you know,
within the,
the,
uh,
the Internet,
you go into a page,
it doesn't work.
You're gone immediately.
So the same thing applies to a badly designed garden.
If it's badly designed,
if it doesn't work,
nevermind the look or the,
you know,
the beauty or of whatever,
it can be beautiful.
But if it doesn't work,
it's annoying and you're,
you just don't want to be in this space.
So basically our gardens from a tangible perspective are,
are there spaces for living and they need to work.
It's really simple.
And a,
the first thing I get my clients to do is do out list.
And I'm sorry,
the second thing,
after dreaming,
get them to do a list of how they spend their day in the garden.
So basically how they,
the most boring stuff,
I hang my washing out,
you know,
the dog goes around,
the kids,
go to the trampoline,
all of those kinds of things.
Um,
but also to,
to say I like to entertain,
so it'd be nice to have a pool to dangle our legs and et cetera.
That's also the bloom garden this year dangling our leg.
So I had to include that.
Um,
so that's just really an idea of what your day looks like in the garden and all
the things the garden needs to,
to um,
function for you.
Like,
so the functions of the garden and then the list of functional requirements.
That's it.
Basically,
really simple,
really easy.
List out everything you need in the actual garden.
And it doesn't need to be super detailed,
but you need this because the next step is putting it onto paper.
And when you put it onto paper,
you need to tick off each and every single one of those.
And if one of them is missing,
then the garden's not going to work 100%.
So that was a client of mine and Strand and sluggo.
Um,
the job was kind of half done.
The builders still onsite,
the dog,
which they weren't supposed to have a dog.
The whole garden was based around them not having kids or a dog.
They now have a child underdog.
Um,
and he destroyed the garden.
But this was before we did the garden.
Um,
and you can see it's,
there's nothing there and it's,
it looks horrendous.
The house is getting there.
Everything is brilliant,
but a lot of spaces that you see,
um,
you have to assess really,
really well in order to get the design right.
So you're looking at everything from soil samples aspect,
garden climbers probably pretty boring at this stage,
but it's so important.
So even if you have like a small balcony,
um,
you need to make sure that you address things like wind privacy views,
you know,
to,
to make sure you don't make any mistakes and then end up with,
you know,
the neighbor right there looking in at you even though you wanted this enclosed
private haven.
So they're all things you need to list out at the very start.
Obviously for bigger sites that gets a lot more complicated and you need to put
in more detail.
Sometimes we get surveyors in because it's too detailed to do with slopes and
all that kind of stuff.
But for small spaces,
it's,
it's relatively easy to do the Ma,
the main thing,
common sense,
you know,
you're looking at views.
Um,
does it have lights?
So you're looking at the strengths of the space,
um,
and how can you enhance them.
That's really important.
And then you're also looking at the challenges.
So you can see the two there.
Um,
all the guard,
we do a show called Archie Super Garden and pretty much all the garden we go
into,
um,
look like that,
you know,
absolute disasters and you know,
after the show leaves then their pet,
yeah,
right.
Five weeks later,
blood,
sweat and tears.
But,
um,
yeah,
I,
you know,
that's actually the joy of it.
Anyway,
it's television and transformation and we all love that.
Um,
but as I said,
nothing is unsolvable.
Um,
and the main thing is having that vision and the dream for what is to come.
And I think some people find that easier than others.
Um,
to imagine like my mom cannot imagine what a garden will look like.
She's like,
how can you even visualize how,
you know,
how,
how it will be.
Um,
probably,
yeah,
probably cause I studied boss,
you know,
it's,
um,
so yeah,
it's all about building on strengths and overcoming challenges,
um,
in guiding in guidance and garden design.
Um,
side measurements.
I touched on that briefly,
just there.
It can be incredibly complicated and it can be very,
very simple to just doing a scaled sketch,
putting in your sizes,
your heights and where the entrance exit,
uh,
where the pathways are and in the first thing is getting the site right,
doing a very simple scale sketch and exploring what,
what's happening on the site.
So I'm not going to go into big detail because that is actually boring.
Um,
but it's good to know and it's detailed in the book as well.
Just to know that that's how you have to start.
If you want to take on a plot of any considerable size,
um,
which actually it's,
you know,
that's kind of a realistic large city garden,
um,
that you could kind of measure out yourself as opposed to getting somebody in to
do it for you.
Um,
so after that comes the functional layer plan,
which is basically taking the functions.
So what the garden has to do for you on plonking them on the plan.
Um,
and they're bubbles,
they're not designed,
they're not beautiful,
they're not details.
They're basically sketched bubbles telling you exactly what happens on site.
So where you need privacy,
where you want a patio,
where you want,
um,
screening where you need to wind screen.
So all the things that you looked at that were challenges need to be addressed
on this in a bubble.
So it doesn't need to represent the shape or anything.
So it's actually really easy to do.
Um,
and it,
but it's so informative to when you start going to sketch detail and you start
putting in,
um,
details in the,
in it.
So that brings me to the bigger picture.
Great design quite far away from the,
the bubbles.
Um,
this is one of my favorite pictures.
it's Tom Stewart Smith.
He's a UK based designer and um,
it's just such a beautiful picture because it shows how a garden can blend into
the landscape beyond without,
it just feels like it's a part of the landscape.
Um,
and I'll go back to that in a minute.
So what makes good design?
Um,
and are we born designers?
It's an,
it's an interesting question because I don't think we're necessarily born
designers.
Some people are better at it than others,
but it's definitely something you can learn.
Um,
what does help,
and I'm sure a lot of you guys are designed based or from design backgrounds,
um,
so you'd be aware of a lot of these principles,
and the fact that they do kind of influence everything from car designed to
Penn,
designed to,
you know,
everything has those principles.
And again,
it goes back to what,
what works and functions.
It goes back to the principles of,
um,
these four.
And then another one I'll talk about after the first one would look at briefly
is the unity and harmony.
And we'll talk about it just in the garden setting,
um,
and how it works with the house,
the garden and the setting.
And that's the picture I showed you before.
This is the same one in winter at the bottom.
Um,
again,
Tom Stewart Smith and the top one too.
Um,
and it just shows how,
um,
how the house,
first of all is linked with the garden.
You can see the colors the has picked up on the red brick,
the grasses and the water in the sizes.
So you've got a connection between the house and the garden,
the design space.
And then beyond that you have a connection of the design garden with the
landscape beyond.
So in the landscape beyond,
for example,
you've got darker spots of the big trees and Tom's brought that into the
foreground of,
um,
of the garden by having darker shapes,
the topiary shapes in the front,
and then the lighter pawns,
which are kind of echo what's going on behind.
So that creates unity and harmony because you're blending all of that together.
Um,
simplicity.
I mean the pros and gardens are a huge influence for me and I think are a great
example of simplicity.
Less is more.
And I think that really applies to,
um,
you know,
online as well.
There's so much being chucked at you all the time.
Um,
that it's really nice to have a calm,
simple design sometimes.
You know,
there's nothing more I like more than looking at a website that's just like,
ah,
Cam,
not too many ads,
not too many things being thrown at you,
you know.
But of course there has to be a balance,
which brings me to know it's a sweet,
it should bring me to balance.
Really,
we use scale and proportion.
Um,
so really same thing as the links between the house and the setting and the
views beyond,
uh,
the garden.
It's the relationship between the house.
So you don't want the house to be absolutely gigantic and person to feel really
small.
Same thing.
The planting.
So the trees can't be tiny and the house really big or vice versa.
So there's gotta be a relationship between everything that's happening in the
space,
the landscape beyond,
and then also obviously the house and the person because we can't forget that
it's you that's experiencing that space.
Okay.
On the best way of doing that is to start sketching or,
or thinking in three d as opposed to two d flat way.
There's Alice,
um,
there's balance.
Um,
so balance is really all about everything coming together in a pleasing
composition.
Um,
and there's so much that,
that work that,
that comes into that from all the other things we looked at scale and
proportion.
Um,
it's,
it's actually really easy to get balance right when you have a symmetrical
garden.
So the likes of the law Hambro if you take that as inspiration,
it's quite easy to get it right because you've got that in here at symmetry was
if you kind of push it to being asymmetrical,
the,
the design,
it does get a little bit harder because you need to make sure you get the
balance of the forms,
the shapes,
the sizes and all of that.
Right?
So it does get a little bit trickier.
You'd also have mystery,
excitement,
light and darkness,
uh,
balance and color.
Um,
and structures also need to be balanced.
So there are great ways I think to start.
Um,
looking at design,
I don't know how,
how,
what percentage of you guys are designed based,
um,
or have a background in design.
So I should've probably asked that at the start.
I'm sure you're aware of,
of some of these are most of these.
Um,
but they're,
they're a great thing to even,
even if you do know on,
you're aware of them to make sure your mind yourself off on our kind of regular
basis.
The other thing that,
um,
that I always find fascinating to look at is the golden ratio.
And again,
you're probably all aware of it.
Um,
but I find it quite interesting in garden design because you're looking at
nature to inform nature.
So,
you know,
from,
from ferns on the way they grow to,
um,
you know,
succulents.
There was actually a garden at Chelsea,
which is based all around the mathematics of geometry.
Um,
which had the meant on the right there had a lot of those kinds of shapes.
And forms on the mathematics behind it are just like,
I,
I don't do maths.
To me it's absolutely baffling,
but it's incredible.
It's really inspiring to look at and to apply to projects,
um,
on the fact that,
it's also founded our bodies and the fact that,
you know,
repeats and it's just,
it's incredible.
It's,
it's,
I find it really,
really interesting that when you clench your fist,
it forms into a perfect,
uh,
golden ratio curl,
but that can inform,
that does and can inform,
um,
a huge amount of design.
And I very cheekily stuck it on top of Google.
So I don't know if that actually does,
but it kind of works.
But it works in garden design,
the apple logo.
So that's,
I'm car design and everything.
It kind of influences everything.
And the reason for that is really because we're using,
one is inherently found in nature and that's informing design.
So it's kind of,
it's an interesting cycle.
So the next thing is I'm choosing shapes for the garden.
So we've gone and looked at the functions of the garden and putting that in in
bubbles.
Um,
and how it works in how we make sure everything is included that you want and
need in a garden.
And the next bit is,
um,
how to actually put that into a plan that you can work from.
And um,
personally I,
I go through the same thing and I recognize this couple of years ago and I went,
oh,
okay,
that's what's happening.
I go through the same kind of
problem every time I have a design job,
I started off going,
this is going to be amazing.
It's going to be such a good project.
And then I started sketching and I start doing stuff and I'm like,
oh my God,
it's going to be a disaster.
It's going to be horrendous.
The client's going to hate us.
And then I start doing more on it and force myself through that and I come at
the other end to go,
okay,
it's going to be fine.
It'll be great,
it'll be good.
So I think a huge amount of people go through that.
I think designers in general always go through that kind of stage of self doubt.
And the hardest part is actually this,
which is for me personally is putting the shapes and making decisions as opposed
to just messing and playing.
So,
um,
I was happy when I learned that it is actually very easy to do that.
Basically you take the,
the functional layer plan with the bubbles and you sketch over that with um,
with uh,
either a layout paper or tracing paper and you just explore the shapes based on
what you have from those bubbles because you know,
you want the patio at the back door because that's where you want to go from the
kitchen where the door is.
So,
you know,
you want it there,
you just need to decide on shapes.
You need to decide how they link to each other.
So you've already made a lot of decisions without knowing it.
You've placed the patio where it wants to go.
You've put the,
um,
the,
the trampoline where you can see the kids from the kitchen.
You know,
you've done all of that background work without realizing.
So you just explore and you start looking at shapes and what works.
Um,
you can have,
I can see the square,
it's free form circles,
combination.
Um,
you can,
you can have completely free form shapes.
It's really what appeals to you and mostly actually what your concept once.
So if you have a very loose meadow style garden and you want it to be,
feel really wild,
then unless you're doing it on purpose,
you're not gonna introduce,
you know,
large concrete slabs,
which I actually love the idea of.
But you know,
then you'd be breaking those rules for a reason,
if that's what you wanted to do.
Um,
so it depends on,
on what the concept is to make it work for you.
And then after that,
if you've chosen your shapes,
you've decided where everything goes comes the really,
really exciting part because you've got your concept,
you know how it's supposed to feel.
Um,
and you get to play around basically with,
um,
materials,
colors,
planting,
um,
and it just all follows your concept.
So in my case,
if it's the Alhambra,
um,
God,
I'd love and now hamper guard.
And actually now that I think about it,
don't Google my garden.
Whatever you do,
I don't know if technology is not advanced yet to zoom in,
write down is this [inaudible] it's an a mess.
Um,
but basically it all comes down to your concept and how to um,
make,
bring that concept to life through materials,
colors and planting.
Is it really like,
like can you actually see different plants?
No,
no,
no.
It's okay.
Not much to see.
I've had a very busy year.
That's crazy.
I digress.
Um,
so the concept,
um,
again that goes back to the idea of kind of fleshing out the whole design to
suit your field and to suit what you've,
what your dream is,
you know.
So,
um,
if it was a sea side garden,
you know,
what do you bring into to your bring,
bringing pebbles and then also think,
and I go into this in the book,
don't be afraid to go for all the materials that are expected and then take some
out and break the rules.
And if it was a seaside gardens,
pebbles and ropes and all that,
you know,
get rid of the ropes and replace it with rusted metal or get rid of,
the,
the expected pebble and replace it with concrete or do something that makes it
new and fresh and not the,
you know,
the expected.
Um,
I don't think I say it there,
but that's,
that's outlined in the book and it's actually a big part of,
I think what makes really good garden design is breaking the rules once you know
them,
once you know what you want to achieve.
Um,
so being selective,
if you're going to go for colors and materials,
choose two colors too strong colors and two strong materials.
Don't go mad.
Um,
because you want the concept to be really,
really strong and you can always add a little bits here and there.
You can always create a little rooms that have separate fields,
but you can see it in this,
you know,
the,
the strength of that rostered corten steel.
And then picking up on that tiny little planting bits in that same color,
um,
just balances so well.
Um,
this one again,
you can see the designer,
Luciano Google has chosen loads and kind of neutral muted tones.
They're different colors,
but loads of,
um,
different materials,
but they all work because they're all neutrals.
So again,
the pilot is really simple,
really clean,
same designer.
Um,
again,
he loves neutrals.
Um,
but it really allows structure and form to jump out at you while it's,
if there was too many colors there,
you wouldn't see those bulls shapes.
You wouldn't see the,
the,
the multi-stemmed trees.
And then this one loose bargain.
He's,
um,
a Mexican architect.
Um,
so he,
he chose loads of different colors for the space,
but he used one material.
So the colors are,
there's plenty of color,
the color of the sky and the water and loads of colors,
but the same material pretty much throughout.
And then the last slide is really to show that,
you know,
vegetable growing can actually be pretty too.
It doesn't have to be a kind of ugly,
um,
you know,
plus you can't actually use cool materials like the wicker and the timber and
the terracotta and make it really colorful and pretty.
Um,
so the last bit I'll go into is the planting perfection,
uh,
the choosing planting.
So again,
the planting that you choose needs to follow your concept.
So,
um,
if your concept is,
you know,
you want to jungle haven in,
in [inaudible],
um,
you need to make sure all the plants you choose or not only work for Ireland
worked for the space,
but then they also work for,
um,
for the,
the concept.
And,
uh,
so you study what works,
what have the jungle looks,
you know,
big leaves,
the foliage,
the bamboo,
um,
and how to make that work in.
And it's totally workable.
I just wrote an article about that actually.
Um,
and it can work really,
really well and look really lush and jungle like,
um,
and again,
for the planting,
we're also considering the,
the principles of design,
which are really,
so one more thing is right plant right place.
Um,
and it's really about a huge amount of interest these days has been put into
creating sustainable gardens that grow themselves as opposed to having to
maintain all the time.
And it's really,
it's really opened up a lot of new,
um,
kind of avenues for,
for young designers in like Chelsea and bloom and all those places,
um,
where you're not stuck in kind of old traditions,
which don't work really,
um,
unless you have huge amounts of time.
So that's what we're talking about here is,
um,
the idea of having organic ecosystems not just grow on that you can let die down
in winter and then come back up and there's that,
that cycle,
that natural cycle
and yet feel like they've been there forever.
I mean,
that bottom one is a,
is a Chelsea Garden,
you know,
you never think it looks like it's in the middle of the province.
So there's a few different planting styles and I just go through them really
quickly because they're all in the book.
Um,
and there's so many of them in the book.
I've pulled out like four or five of them.
Um,
and basically the cottage style planting,
which is that real old English,
um,
formal style and looks like it's kind of being scattered there,
but it's actually pretty high maintenance because you've got kind of the box
balls and you know,
all of the perennials dying down and the bulbs that have to be taken up and all
of that kind of stuff.
Um,
modernist started planting,
which is very clean,
very modern.
A lot of that gets combined with kind of naturalistic kind of wild meadow
planting,
which works really well.
You can see the top one there is a Chelsea Garden and they've kind of done that.
Um,
that's the naturalistic planting,
which really echoes what's happening in nature.
And the idea of naturalistic planting is that it does just scatter and grow and
evolve into something fresh and new.
And that has really been focused on planting styles in the past 10 years or so
that it's gone away from that Uber,
um,
planned and maintained idea to a more kind of letting nature do what it wants to
do and embracing that.
Okay.
So that brings me back to the core of what we do and just if there's anything
that I'd love you guys to go away with today after the talk is,
um,
that connection between,
first of all,
everything that we do as people,
um,
whether it's a garden design or an online platform or,
or any other creative or design based,
um,
uh,
endeavor that there is always that connection on the connection is the person
and the experience on,
um,
much like garden design,
everything is personal.
Um,
and to keep that connection in mind.
Thank you.
I was dreading that I'm doing now.
That was crazy.
So was that was really,
I let them keep going here,
middle.
That was
really entertaining and really informative.
Um,
so we're going to open up to audience questions in minutes.
I'm just going to ask maybe the first question.
So the reality for some people me is that I love the idea of having a beautiful
garden or like we talked about my,
my little patio,
but I do struggle to keep the od potted plant alive.
Okay.
Beyond me.
So is it a baby step pre prebook oh God no I do.
Well that goes back to the right plant,
right place.
You know,
finding out what plants really need I guess.
So I'm identifying what the plant that you choose,
what that,
what the needs are,
what the soil needs are,
was the moisture levels are making sure there's enough drainage,
making sure there's not,
you know,
that it doesn't dry out.
So if you do have say a pot,
you can control that.
So that's easy.
You just need to inform yourself.
So use Google and find out exactly what the plant needs.
Um,
I actually use it on a daily basis for all sorts of stuff from cooking to God
knows what.
So,
um,
but yeah,
to,
to inform yourself of what that plant needs or to go,
right.
I have,
don't have huge amounts of rainfall in that particular area in the garden where
I have the pots and to go,
right,
I'm going to use dry drought friendly plants and then find out what you could
plant there and then create a scheme around that.
So dry,
you know,
kind of desert feel,
space of grasses or something like that.
So it goes back to what you said a while ago about just the knowledge for me,
baby steps,
little dainty stuff.
Am I going to ask one more question then I go to the audience?
Um,
if if a community,
and I just say a group of people who live in a housing estate decided to have a,
to create a small community garden or allotment.
Um,
would you have any advice on what they could do to make that a success?
Ooh,
um,
planning,
definitely huge thing.
Make sure that you know exactly what you're doing.
Um,
look at who's going to be using it.
So going back to the user is going to be,
um,
you know,
the younger people in the community,
will they be involved?
Um,
is it going to be older people so you might raise beds?
so finding it,
finding out the user is probably the main thing.
Um,
identifying who'll be using it,
um,
and then making it fun.
Making sure that like the kids get involved and you know,
everybody wants to be there.
So maybe have some sort of a social space or something in it,
like a small gazebo or a little poly tunnel where everyone gets a hangout and,
because then you want to be there and you'll want to put work in.
Okay.
That's great.
We've got any questions from the audience but one here,
um,
probably get asked this one all the times that on
I can hear you.
Yep.
Great.
Eh,
what's your take on a synthetic grass?
Cause it's sort of,
when you're doing a lot of other stuff,
it seems like it's an easy option,
but is it the right option?
Um,
it's funny because a lot of garden designers,
we have,
we had a big discussion about this during Super Garden and 90% of the people
that we were talking to at the time were like,
oh,
it's horrible,
but there's an absolute place for it.
Um,
like today I FM have it on their roof garden and they were ashamed of it and I
was like,
no,
but why would you put real grass?
There will be,
you know,
head wrecking.
So I think it depends on your needs,
on your needs,
on what you need it for.
And if you think it will make your life easier,
um,
on better and you can work it into the design in such a way that it looks good,
then absolutely.
Why not?
You know,
I wouldn't be a snob about it.
I think a lot of people do and they almost do it to pretend,
you know.
Thank you.
Great.
Cool.
Got 'em one of the second road here.
Great.
We just have to check with the microphone's working before we got us.
Get a teacher.
That's fine.
Just want to make sure that we hear you on the recording.
Thank you.
Totally natural.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's working.
Okay.
Thank you so much for the talk.
I've looks absolutely amazing and makes me wish to just drop my job and start
gardening all week.
You come up for me?
Yes.
Um,
what can we do?
Like most of us,
we can't probably afford at this stage,
the garden in Dublin.
Um,
let,
let alone like anything in Dublin.
Um,
what,
what can we do to create a nice space and our balconies or if we don't even have
like the knee maybe inside like a small oasis to relax and enjoy what we saw on
the slides.
Um,
well first thing is I'm,
I'm concerned with are quite a lot because I hate the idea of design being
exclusive and the idea that only those that have like 100,000 euro to spend
under design can afford it.
And the first garden I did actually,
because I don't think there's any pictures of it in this,
um,
uh,
bloom was made with scaffold old scaffolding planks.
And so if you want to create something really special without putting huge
amounts of money into it,
you have to kind of rethink the materials you're using.
Um,
you have to rethink the amount of time you want to put into it.
So those scaffolding planks,
they looked absolutely stunning when we were done with them,
but we sanded and sanded and sanded,
didn't sound it.
And to get them to look really well and then,
you know,
stay in them again and again and again.
So re-imagining old materials is great,
but then everybody's Kinda started catching on to that too.
So like scaffolding,
planks are hard to get,
you know,
what'd you call them?
Pilots and you know,
um,
but be creative,
you know,
get,
get hands on yourself and it doesn't need to cost a huge amount of money.
Um,
it's hard to be specific because I don't know exactly what you're talking about,
but,
um,
say if you were,
you know,
instead of if you wanted something on a,
on a window sill insight,
instead of just getting a plastic window box,
create something,
you know,
even if it's made with driftwood or made with timber that you,
you staying up to suit the color scheme inside,
um,
or,
uh,
go to Pinterest and you know,
research certain things and,
you know,
there's so many ideas you can kind of bring in to the home by just getting
creative yourself.
I know that's a really bad answer,
but,
so it's about making it,
it's creativity.
Yes.
Not just a quick fix,
which is what I kind of tend to do.
But that in that way you can work design principles into it and then you'll
create something beautiful as opposed to just,
you know,
placing something that somebody else mightn't have put a huge amount of thought
into.
So it's the thought process and then making it personal to you.
You know,
cause if you make it yourself or have it made,
um,
even if it is like say a gate,
a rostered steel gate,
it might be old materials,
but you filled it up so you know it's going to be perfect for you
anywhere.
Audience questions.
Um,
so I'm moving into a new house.
We'd spoke new house,
um,
in,
uh,
just off the road.
Um,
and we've got to red food,
basic square garden,
nothing spectacular.
Right now it's Robel.
Um,
myself and my wife were talking about what we do from the star.
Right.
So for example,
obviously we be busy inside the house,
but do you have any advice in terms of if we wanted to put down that's a trees
first we start from begun work with down or do we start with like,
you know,
to potted plants and work our way up?
Have you kind of come across that before?
Where would you start?
Oh,
loads.
Um,
and the,
the main thing I think is before you start planting,
before we start doing anything is dreaming that,
that kind of figuring out what you want from the garden before you start placing
things.
And,
um,
even before you start going into the,
you know,
the privacy and all of those kinds of things.
So making sure that your dream for the house,
which you probably already have and you have,
you know,
materials and features in there that you want to pick up on and the style of the
house,
try and bleed that out.
So pick up on colors,
materials on the floor,
like if you have,
say concrete floors,
bleed it out or if there's tiles or timber,
you know,
try and continue that because then it will become an extension of your living
space.
But making sure you identify what kind of feel you want,
what kind of style you want,
um,
and then bleeding that in through the whole space.
You know,
I'm connecting them and then you can,
you can always start by planting a few trees if you wanted to now and then work
with the rest around that.
But just make sure that you don't end up putting them somewhere where you don't
want them.
So making sure you follow the process in your head a little bit of where do I
need privacy,
um,
where do I need a windscreen?
So do analyze the side of it before you look at trees or that sort of thing.
If I have time for one more question.
Any final audience questions?
No.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Two more actually will fit the whole thing.
It's a very practical question.
Yeah.
Um,
I was wondering like is there any place that you would recommend us to go to?
If we want to design,
for example,
our little balcony or so,
um,
like a garden center we can go through that you could really recommend.
Because as far I looked for plants and I finally went to Ikea and they were all
sold out.
So that wasn't really a success.
So maybe there is a better place to go to that's also affordable.
And you're talking about outdoor plants or just as in indoor?
I Dunno,
maybe.
I mean there's loads of places in and around Dublin.
There's a place called garden world.
I don't know if you've come across garden world and kill Quaid and Oak Hill.
Cool.
Good.
Quite can't remember.
I think it's,
yeah,
in Wicklow.
Um,
they're fantastic.
They have incredible plants.
Uh,
a good quality plants too.
I generally deal more with the wholesale.
Um,
and uh,
things are larger plants,
you know,
um,
but they're,
they're fantastic.
Um,
and they have a huge selection and they're very knowledgeable so they'll
actually help talk you through whatever you need or,
um,
materials wise,
I glove salvage yards.
So if you have,
you know,
ideas for a balcony or something like that to go to old architectural salvage
and just choose out.
Interesting.
Cool.
You know,
even one thing and then build around if you don't have a specific idea in mind.
Okay.
A place more in the city center ish would be plant life on cork storage.
Yup.
Closer by.
Yeah.
If you don't have a car.
Uh,
my question kind of comes back to what we discussed earlier.
It's like a round style though about style.
Is there like an Irish style that you've seen over the years or how has that
developed or is there something that makes Irish gardens stand out from auto,
let's say,
European Gardens?
Um,
it's interesting because for a long time Irish design would have been influenced
hugely by the likes of Chelsea,
the t,
the rhs shows,
Tatton Park,
um,
and all of the big shows,
garden shows,
show garden shows in the UK.
Um,
I think since the,
um,
since since bloon was launched,
which is what,
11 years ago now,
I think,
um,
that kind of gave Irish design is a platform here,
to showcase.
So I think there's been a huge shift in that.
Um,
and I think an Irish planting style and field has developed,
um,
which is a little bit more relaxed and natural than say its English counterpart.
Having said that,
I mean you know,
trends kind of cross over and back and you've got trends coming from the south
of France and there's like an overall trend of naturalistic planting and
sustainability.
And I'm allowing gardens to just be the way they want to be.
Um,
which actually in last year it came back a little bit to being more structured
again.
Um,
so there are trends that go across all of them,
but I do think Irish designers have developed their own styles.
Um,
and I think this year at bloom,
it was interesting to see,
there was a lot of interest at Chelsea and the Chelsea designers were tweeting a
lot about designers here and about what gardens they liked and stuff,
which was amazing,
you know,
to,
to have that coming back to Ireland.
That's great.
Thank you.